The most common task you'll
complete on Piazza is reading.
>From the home screen on Piazza, you can
read any of the topics on the left.
Just click the topic to
load it in the main window.
The numbers on the topics
indicate how many updates there
have been since you
last viewed the topic.
You'll notice that the topics are
flagged with other information as well.
This icon with the four lines
indicates a topic is a note.
That means that the topic is more of
a discussion, not a question and answer.
This icon with the three bars is for
a poll where you can vote on something.
If the topic is a question,
it will either appear in
red if it is unresolved, or
it will have icons showing it has been
resolved by a student or instructor.
For example,
this question is unresolved.
We can see there is no answer provided,
and so it appears in red on the left.
A yellow i icon means that the question
has received an instructor's answer.
A green s icon means that the question
has received a student answer.
For example, in this topic we see the
question has received both instructor
and student answers.
So both icons appear.
A check mark on top of the green s
means that an instructor has
endorsed a student's answer.
There may also be some flags on
the left side of the topic list.
This flag means the topic or
question was posted by an instructor.
This flag means the topic is only
visible to you and the instructor.
visible to a particular subgroup,
like a project group, or a study group.
Finally, there are also
flags below the questions.
Sometimes an instructor will endorse
a question or a note as a good note, and
this will appear.
Unresolved followups
are also noted below.
These refer to the followup discussion,
which we'll talk about in a bit.
>> Many of our OMS classes can have
several hundred students in them.
And, as such,
the topic list can get very large and
can be pretty overwhelming.
But, remember, there's not usually
nearly as much content there as there
actually appears to be.
But to kind of wade through it, I'd like
to show you one of my favorite features.
It's hidden under menu in Piazza.
It's the archive feature.
To get to the archive feature,
mouse over a topic.
And then hover over the arrow
that appears on the left.
Then come down to Archive.
Click it and the topic will no
longer appear in your topic list.
Archiving a topic will remove
it from your topic list, but
it won't remove it from everyone else.
And archived topics are still available
to you in a way we'll talk about a bit
later, but it won't be there
to clutter up your view.
So if you're reasonably sure that
a topic isn't going to have any updates
that are going to interest you.
Or, if you feel like the topic
has reached its logical end,
feel free to archive it like
this to keep it out of your way.
You can also use this menu to subscribe
to e-mail updates about a thread by
clicking Follow.
Or to mark a thread as unread if
you want to make sure to come back
to it later.